okay so i'm going to talk about one
other method that's a little bit
superior to bonfroni in some ways and uh
and but it's a little more complicated
so it's not quite as popular i think but
let me quickly go through how this
approach works so this is known as
holmes method
and it starts the same way as bonferroni
you just perform standard hypotheses
tests on your m hypotheses and calculate
standard p-values p1 through pm so it's
exactly the same as before
but now what we do is we order the p
values from the smallest to the largest
so this p one with parentheses just
represents the smallest p value p two is
the second etc so they ordered from
smallest to largest
and then we apply this rather strange
looking calculation
where we try to find the first p-value
where
the value of that p-value is greater
than alpha say five percent if that was
our cut-off let's say
over m plus one minus j so just to give
you a feeling for that suppose that j is
one then the smallest p value we'd be
looking at that and comparing it to
alpha over m
or alpha over m plus one minus one so
alpha over m which of course is the same
as the bonferroni cutoff so for the
smallest p-value we're looking to see
whether that value is
past alpha over m if it's not then we go
on to the second p-value and we ask is
the second smallest p-value greater than
alpha over m minus one
if not then we go to the third one is
that smaller than alpha over m minus two
et cetera and we find the first point
where we break that rule where the
p-value is above that value and then we
simply reject all null hypotheses where
the p-value for that null hypothesis is
less than this cut-off p-value
so
this is also guaranteed to control the
family-wise error rate and it turns out
that it often will reject more
hypotheses than the bonferroni method
it's always going to reject at least as
many as the bonferroni method right yes
so so and you can see that because you
compare the smallest p-value to alpha
over m so if bond if holmes fails to
reject that p-value then bond for only
won't reject that either
so again let's look at this on the fund
manager data so i've ordered the
p-values now from smallest to largest
and it turns out that when we apply homs
procedure that the first two null
hypotheses get rejected and that's
because the smallest p-value is less
than .01 that's the alpha over m
but the second p-value
is also less than alpha over m minus one
and that turns out to be point zero one
two five so now fund manager three just
sneaks in under the threshold right
under the wire under the wire and is
also rejected which is uh a good outcome
for the man and just to be clear that's
fun management three because p
parentheses two
is the second smallest p value and that
corresponds to manager three right
but of course the other managers the p
p-values are still very large so we
don't reject those
so this is just a a very simple example
of a situation where homer manages to
reject two null hypotheses but
bonferroni does one but both methods are
controlling the family-wise error rate
at five percent and by the way this is
because bonferroni is sometimes overly
conservative
we guarantee the uh the family-wise
error rates no more than five percent
but in practice it might be quite a bit
less than five percent so we've been
overly conservative
these pictures here just illustrate one
more way that you can see hong beating
out bonferroni so here we have 10
different hypothesis tests that we
performed and these are the p-values
associated with those hypothesis tests
ordered from smallest to largest
the black horizontal line here is the
alpha over m threshold that bonferroni
uses so every point under that is
rejected by bonferroni so here alpha is
0.05 and m is 10. so that's the 0.005
level in black exactly
and the blue line here is the cutoff for
home after you order the p values from
smallest to largest and you can see that
it starts at exactly the same point as
bonferroni but then is strictly above
that
the black points are where both holm and
bonferroni get the same conclusion
either rejecting or failing to reject
but this one red point you see at number
eight here
is rejected by home because it's below
the blue line but is not rejected by
bonferroni so that's like a the red one
is a discovery that we made using the
home correction but not using the
bonferroni correction and we want to
make as many discoveries as possible
subject to controlling the family-wise
error rate so that red one represents a
real win for home exactly
and just one more picture to illustrate
a more extreme example here this is sort
of unusually extreme but this
illustrates that here we've got only
three hypotheses rejected by the
bonferroni approach but we actually
managed to reject eight hypotheses using
whole so potentially you can get a lot
more discoveries this way
okay so which is preferable again it
just comes down to which you prefer
bonferroni is a little simpler home is
slightly more complicated though not
dramatically both will reject the
family-wise error rate holm is a better
choice in terms of getting more
rejections well i think this has to do
with if whether you're a is it
satisficer versus maximizer
because i personally think bonferroni is
usually good enough and home is just a
little bit show-offy
but um
yeah and and and let's be honest i'm
like just lazy to the level where i do
bonferroni and along with 99 of other
people because uh bonferroni is by far
the most popular approach here yeah but
with alpha equals .01 gareth can reject
the null hypothesis because he's in that
one percent